i look down on him because i am upper
class i look up to him because he is
upperclass i know my place
[Music]
in the 21st century you might think
climbing the social ladder has got
easier but actually it's getting harder
[Music]
in many rich countries the class you're
born into still dominates your chances
of making it
no one talks about these sort of hidden
privileges that are going on underneath
the surface
even in america the so-called land of
opportunity your chances of climbing up
the income ladder are some of the lowest
in the rich world
what the data suggests is that we're not
such a land of opportunity after all
this lack of social mobility is causing
serious political rifts
when people feel they just don't have a
shot
that's what leads to disaffection it
leads to radicalism in politics
so what's gone wrong and what can be
done
to improve social mobility
[Music]
so this is where i grew up
feels like a lifetime ago to be honest
as a child
sophie pender lived on a council estate
and says hardly anyone thought she would
make anything of her life
it's hard to expect anything from
someone who has
grown up where their dad is an alcoholic
and a drug addict i think people just
expect them to follow the path that
their parents have taken
but sophie has defied expectations
she now works for a top law firm
and is passionate about helping
working-class people to get ahead
people have felt comfortable insulting
me because in their mind they think well
if you're working class you can change
that the onus is on you if you live on a
council state that's your fault but
actually it's a whole host of factors
that mean that someone might not have
had you know the opportunities available
to them
sophie is the exception to the rule
britain has a social mobility problem
if you're born at the bottom here your
chances of moving up the income ladder
are lower than in many other rich
countries
there's just a 9 probability of moving
from the bottom of the income ladder
to the top
it's even lower in america
but to put that in context you're almost
50 percent more likely to make it to the
top if you live in places like canada or
denmark this is known as relative social
mobility
part of the reason for these differences
is the level of wealth income inequality
and welfare provision in each country
i think america is the poster child for
rising uh income and wealth inequality
the way i like to think about it is that
when you have a lot of income inequality
the rungs on the ladder of opportunity
are much further apart
and that makes it harder to climb that
ladder
those at the very top of the ladder have
also pulled away from everyone else
in 1975 the share of taxable income
going to the top 1 in america was 9
by 2018 that had more than doubled
and declining social mobility is bad
news for american society
the fact that if you are not from that
privileged background that you feel like
your kids are set up for failure to some
degree that's a very powerful political
impulse and a real source of energy for
populist movements on the left and the
right not just in america but also
across the world
it used to be much easier to get ahead
september 2nd 1945 and america's joy
bubbled over into unrestrained jubilee
after the second world war countries
such as america and britain enjoyed a
social mobility boom
government is big business but far from
the only one an expansion in
professional and managerial jobs allowed
many working-class people to move up the
income ladder
and as a result if you were born in the
post-war years in america you had a 90
chance of making more money than your
parents a picnic it's for the children
but this
didn't last
from a high in the 1940s absolute
mobility has been falling
and the generation of children born in
the 1980s had just a 50 percent chance
of making more money than their parents
one team of economists have dubbed this
phenomenon the fading american dream
since the second world war in america
absolute mobility has declined
and those chances have declined uh
pretty steadily for each younger
generation in america so if you're part
of the millennial generation uh you
should be pretty uh disturbed by all of
this
[Music]
there's one divide which has become
especially significant
whether you've been to university
or not
in rich countries there has been an
economic shift away from manufacturing
towards more service-based industries
which means there are now fewer openings
for those without a degree
education has now become the new
determinant of people's incomes and life
chances much more than it was 50 or 60
years ago now that revolution has minted
winners particularly in highly paid
service sector jobs doctors and lawyers
for the lower and middle class it
condemns them to a bit more of a
precarious financial situation
so what can be done to bridge this
social divide and widen access to higher
education
[Music]
in britain a new breed of state schools
like this one have sprung up catapulting
kids from lower income families into top
universities
so now let's solve this problem and then
talk about what that k value means in
the context the ncs is located in newham
london's second poorest borough
while nearly half the students here are
on bursaries or qualify for free school
meals
an indicator of deprivation
last year 95 went on to top universities
in britain we're humans we have the same
capacities we should be able to do the
same thing
most will be the first in their family
to get a degree let alone one from an
elite university
my parents haven't gone to university so
i didn't really have like mentors to
guide me and like now me aspiring to go
to like oxbridge that's a huge deal
coming from like a working-class
background like immigrant parents they
really like to push the education thing
so much because they want their
sacrifice to matter they want children
to break the class barriers that maybe
maybe acted as an actual barrier for
them
head teacher moss in ismail grew up
nearby and left a six-figure salary as a
lawyer to run the school
he is passionate about boosting social
mobility
where you're born shouldn't dictate
where you end up and just because you're
not born with a silver spoon in your
mouth but if you're talented you should
be able to realize your potential
he keeps the school's performance in
constant view on his office window
he says improving students life chances
means running a so-called super
curriculum
as soon as you hit this wall and go
outside of the box the potential energy
is infinity and today it's quantum
mechanics
i think the difference between what we
do and what other schools may lack is
the forensic focus on the fundamentals
being unashamedly academic
unapologetically ambitious for our young
people
it probably helps that the school only
takes the very brightest last year they
had 4 thousand applications for 300
places
how many pieces of clothing
and schools like this
are starting to make a difference by
challenging private fee paying schools
bastions of britain's class system
you're
not so clever
[Music]
schools like eaton college have long
been pilloried in comedy sketches like
this for disproportionately feeding
britain's elite
[Music]
just over a third of the nation's prime
ministers were educated there
but private schools hold over elite
universities is declining
in 2016
around 40 percent of uk admissions to
oxford and cambridge came from private
fee paying schools despite the fact that
only a small proportion of children
attend them
but by 2020 that figure had dropped to
near a thirty percent
we need to have the largest uh possible
attempt to drill down in societies to
find talent wherever it is the hidden
einsteins as it were and i think this is
one area where britain is doing quite
well compared with the united states
america is one of the only countries in
the world to have legacy admissions
where colleges can actively discriminate
in favor of the children of alumni
43 of white students who graduated from
harvard between 2014 and 2019 didn't get
in on academic merit alone
this helps perpetuate a cycle where if
your parents are wealthy you're more
likely to graduate than if your parents
are poor and did not go to college
what they've created in america is a
national ruling class based on
educational certificates
they're absolutely
obsessed by educational credentials if
you're unfortunate enough to look at the
social pages of the new york times it's
full of saying that so-and-so with a
degree from harvard and married so and
so credentialism has become the new mark
of being a member of the upper classes
in america there have been some
high-profile efforts to equalize the
system of university admissions
[Music]
kavika smith has been at the forefront
[Music]
oh hi honey good to see you it is good
to see you how's the community been
we're trying to build more people like
you yes there's
not enough being done to help low-income
students
in america
growing up he dreamt of going to ucla
but didn't get the grades he needed in
his sats
the standardized tests used in college
admissions
it's a money gimmick
sats were first introduced in 1926
as a way of increasing the pool of
people admitted to harvard
but it didn't work out like that
in recent years asian and white students
have consistently done better on the
tests than black and hispanic students
and wealthier pupils also outperformed
their poorer peers
[Music]
according to the most recent data a
student with a family income under
twenty thousand dollars can expect to
score 136 points less on their writing
sat than someone with a family income of
over two hundred thousand dollars
it is susceptible to being prepared for
so access to test preparation and
particularly expensive test preparation
is disproportionately available to
students from higher income families and
it's really not a level playing field at
all
along with a coalition of community
groups kavika took the university of
california to court over its use of sats
and after a lengthy legal battle
the university dropped the tests from
its admissions process
the university of california system will
no longer consider sat scores for
admission it could reshape the college
admissions process across the entire
country
but the result came too late for kavika
who never made it to ucla
the lawsuit was never about me
it was affirming because i knew that
generations coming after me will no
longer have to experience that level of
discrimination
many more colleges are now reconsidering
their use of sats and legacy admissions
policies
but some argue tinkering with the
admission system will do little to
improve deep rooted inequalities
a lot of the emphasis focuses on elite
institutions i think that that misses
the point for inequality poverty
the composition of uc berkeley student
body i think matters substantially less
than we seem to think it is more
important to think about disparities in
graduation rates from high school than
it is the sort of composition of elite
student bodies the young people of today
deserve the same opportunity to earn
success and accomplishment you have a
better chance of improving social
mobility if you start young
kids from wealthier families tend to
outperform lower income children as
early as primary school
but there is a simple way to boost young
children's chances and it was
demonstrated in this small island nation
[Music]
the story began in the late 1980s
[Music]
so at that time
i would say there was a lot more poverty
than there is now
some of the homes that we went into they
were really really very poor
christine and novalette were part of a
pioneering scheme to help some of the
poorest children get ahead
so we're here with the toys as health
workers they would visit families every
week bringing homemade toys and games
once i see in your uniform mm-hmm always
looking out for you you know i said
sinners come in nurses here
these are the original toys they brought
door to door
many made from household rubbish
[Music]
you would ask the child if they know any
of the pictures
and most of them would know ball because
you know jamaicans are into football so
every little child knows a ball
this is made from old socks
the
mother's reactions were mixed there were
a few wondering what am i going to do
with these things seeing that they were
made out of plastic bottles and so on
but after a few visits they loved it
[Music]
the scheme was the brainchild of
physician sally grantham mcgregor who
was working in kingston at the time
nobody appreciated the importance of
play there were no books there were no
toys the children were just sitting
there in the backyard we called them the
yards doing nothing they had nothing so
that's where i was coming from to try
and
improve equity a little bit
the homemade toys and books help the
kids to develop language and cognitive
skills
what was unique i think was that we
wanted to work with mothers and we
wanted to make it as cheap as possible
but still effective
[Music]
i feel very proud because i see that
other people can come and you know doing
the same thing that we used to go and do
and they are benefiting from it
sally's team together with economists
followed the children who had taken part
in the experiment
the results were extraordinary
20 years after the experiment the
children were earning 25 more than the
control group and at the 30-year
follow-up
they now earned 43
more per hour i mean at the time when we
started i was just desperate to make an
improvement at all
but with the long-term follow-up showing
such benefits
it's incredibly encouraging the
challenge now is to do it at scale
reach more children
versions of the jamaica program have now
been set up across the world
one of the most recent is in china
[Music]
thanks to rapid industrial development
many people here have lifted themselves
out of poverty
meaning the country has a high rate of
what is known as absolute mobility
but your chances of moving from the
lowest rungs of the income ladder to the
top are still very low
it's possible to have a society with
high absolute mobility but still very
low relative mobility and you can think
of emerging market economies like india
and china
[Music]
china in particular has taken 800
million people out of extreme poverty in
the last few decades but it's an
incredibly unequal society as well
it's not just when and what you're
taught as a child which can determine
your life chances
it's also where you're brought up
[Music]
in america
even moving a few blocks can make all
the difference
this is the street i lived on it
literally looks like an alley
dawn used to live in one of the poorer
areas of seattle
you kind of feel worthless
you know being here
you don't think much of yourself being
here
but thanks to a groundbreaking program
she has moved to a new part of the city
it's like the kids who made fun of me in
sixth grade saying that you microwave
your chicken to warm it up it partly
kind of saved me
a little bit because
it has finally allowed me to feel like
things are getting better that all
everything that i've been doing all
these years are leading up to a better
life
under the scheme people who receive
housing vouchers to help cover their
rent are supported and helped with the
costs of moving to areas of greater
opportunity
[Music]
it's part funded by the gates foundation
and based on the work of a group of
economists
using decades of data from the census
bureau they built a so-called
opportunity atlas for america
it's a heat map tracking how much
children born in the late 70s and early
80s would go on to earn as adults
according to the atlas data where you
grow up really matters
if you grow up in a low-income family in
harding county south dakota for example
you can expect to earn much more than
your parents
but if you're raised in hoke county
north carolina
your household income at 35 is likely to
be just 22 000
among the lowest in america
the pattern that jumps out is the
incredibly high mobility rates
of the great plains and upper midwest if
you ask many people what's the highest
mobility place to grow up in the country
they'll often say you know very highly
educated cities on the coast but the
highest mobility rates by far are in
places like iowa and nebraska these are
places where children from low income
families
really have just outstanding outcomes
it's not entirely clear what makes these
places engines of opportunity
the researchers think it's connected to
role models
most of the areas of greatest
opportunity have a high number of two
parent families
as well as good schools and low levels
of segregation
[Music]
according to the atlas data
children growing up in dawn's old area
can expect to earn twelve thousand
dollars a year less than those who grow
up in her new neighborhood
i literally
feel like i'm one of the lottery winners
but even the schemes advocates
acknowledge moving people to better
places is simply too costly and
labor-intensive to be a scalable
solution to improve social mobility
this is never going to be
a broad-based solution because we can't
just move everyone around but on the
other hand if you even just take the
incredibly narrow view that
children who grow up in higher
opportunity neighborhoods will
themselves grow up to earn more as
adults and pay more taxes as adults
you can actually get the program to pay
for itself
due to these
higher outcomes
moving up the social ladder isn't just
about increasing your earnings
it can also be linked to something which
is harder to quantify
social capital
the invisible networks that help
perpetuate the advantages those from
wealthy backgrounds enjoy
social capital is having people you can
turn to oh do you know someone in this
industry or can you help me with the cv
the really kind of like subtle favors
that people can call upon
sophie may be successful now but she is
keenly aware of the importance of social
connections which she lacked when she
started out
i think that i've gone to uni expecting
to make friends on the basis of my
academic interests and my intellect and
what i realized was that actually
university was this like extension of a
public school system that exists in the
uk and it was really strange to me i
didn't have the networks people would
make comments about my accent they would
say you sound really essexy you sound
really chavy
[Music]
sophie has founded a group dedicated to
changing this
we're going to let the defenses down let
the side there that's nice yeah
this is the 93 club
so called after the 93 of students who
attend state schools in britain
effectively what we're doing is we are
packaging up privilege the kind of
privilege that you can't see but is
definitely operating in our society and
we give it back to students from lower
socioeconomic backgrounds
today members are having headshots taken
for linkedin profiles
as well as meeting professional mentors
from some of britain's most successful
firms
and actually the you know some thing
that you think sounds quite mundane if
you explain to someone why that was the
most challenging thing you did it will
come across way better
the 93 club now has nearly 50 branches
and universities across the uk
for some of the newer recruits
the group has been a lifeline whether
you realize it or not your class and
your upbringing ends up playing such a
pivotal role in the rest of your life it
gives you these opportunities and trains
you for example a private school parent
might check the cv for the child but for
example someone like me i can't get my
mother or father to check my cv because
the fact that they're not educated
enough
it will take more than passionate
individuals to improve social mobility
it requires governments to commit to
improving both access to education and
wealth redistribution
it's a huge task
but the post-pandemic world offers a
unique opportunity for change
social mobility and more generally
income inequality has really come to the
fore of the policy discussion if there's
a silver lining of the pandemic
sometimes it takes a big shock like this
in order to really get people focused on
all of these inequalities i think we've
dramatically expanded what might be
possible over the past year relative to
the way people thought about these
problems 15 or 20 years ago
hi i'm madrice colun and i'm the
washington correspondent for the
economist if you'd like to read my
briefing on social mobility then please
click on the link that's opposite me and
if you'd like to watch more of our now
and next series then please click on the
other link thank you very much for
watching and please don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]
you